hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to now
usually on the show and talk about
things you might've seen growing up old
TV shows movies stuff like that but
today today I'm making a special
exception so I can talk to you about the
trailer that premiered right before the
transformer movie you know what I'm
talking about
those of you who don't I'll give you
this giddy alright so it starts off with
a handheld video camera shooting a
going-away party for a guy named Rob for
the most part it's just people joking
drinking talking and saying how much
they're gonna miss Rob after he leaves
the city I don't know who Rob is but I'm
missing him already when suddenly the
power goes out and a loud explosion and
people start screaming and running down
stairs as the camera goes a little glare
which on us as everybody exits outside
that you're a thunderous roaring sound a
thunderous roaring sound what could that
be oh it's a building blowing up dude
it's a building blowing up holy shit
as the building blows up in the
smithereens sense of ruin
fiery death are smashing down on the
onlookers within seconds everything's
being thrown a card house other bits of
rubble a cow can may be not a cow but a
lot of stuff and last but not fucking
least the head of a goddamn Statue of
Liberty good god I just pissed myself
that's the scariest thing I've ever seen
in my entire life I mean it was
terrifying it was incredible he was
especially
I mean oh my god you just wouldn't
believe it what could this horrible
creation of Beelzebub be JJ Abrams may
be a monster he's not that big okay we
know when our lives are going to come to
an end but what is it that's gonna kill
us
oh come on there's got to be more than
that isn't there isn't there Oh Q hey
did you forget something
the title you forgot the title of your
movie what how do you forget the title
of your movie what kind of a ripoff is
that hey you build this on your scale
that shit out of us and then you don't
even tell us what we're supposed to be
afraid of that's bullshit
anyone could be what on earth could a
giant thing that pulls up buildings and
first I have it the Statue of Liberty
everywhere B is it a demon is it a
machine is it Donkey Kong my money's on
Donkey Kong after he gets drunk and all
those barrels of beer he ran pages
through the city seeking out all the
Italian plumbers or you know it is JJ
Abrams maybe it's the black smoke from
lost he got off the island and now he's
looking for a nice industrial plant to
call home no no I bet it's JJ Abrams
production logo the bad robot he goes
stomping through the city looking for
the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man because
there's only room for one giant
homicidal corporate logo in this town
maybe it's not a monster at all maybe
it's Jesus maybe he just wanted to get
the Bible a twist ending and decides to
rampage through the city maybe it's all
four of them maybe it's a giant robotic
Donkey Kong Jesus riding a puff of smoke
holy shit that'd be really cool but
highly improbable
now Google of finding information about
this movie because it's actually a lot
harder than it sounds many people think
the name of the movies Cloverfield but
that's not actually true
Cloverfield it's the fake title they
came up with so that nobody can get an
idea about what this thing really is
which I feel is kind of bad advertising
how can I say see the film purchase a
ticket go into a theater and watch this
motion picture experience if they don't
even know it's fucking called
my credit show what that monster is
offense JJ Abrams gigantic ego
terrorizing the city with his
pretentious advertising will consume
this nation only time will tell my
friend only time will tell
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to it had better be
donkey o'clock